what if i told you 90 of people
completely misunderstand the concept of
competition and here's what i mean by it
i i don't know people that are super
competitive or i don't know people that
are scared of competition and i'm going
to reveal to hear why by the way if this
video this message gives you value give
it a thumbs up and subscribe at the end
let me get right into it so competition
if people understood that competition is
your best friend to help your dream if
your dream becomes a reality without
competition in 22 years with competition
it became a reality in 11 years is it
worth you embracing the concept of
competition let's talk about it okay so
why do most people fear competition they
either lost in the past they had a
humiliating laws it was a public laws
people laughed at you it was
embarrassing you didn't like it the
pressure was unnecessary you had
sleepless nights thinking about a
competition thinking about a debate
thinking about whatever it is and it
created all this angst and you're like
oh my gosh i cannot stand it right okay
to me i've seen competition in three
different levels and embrace one of
these three decide to make one of these
three your best friend so lowest level
of competition that is still healthy for
you
is focusing on beating your prior best
look i don't care what you're doing if
the most calls you made in a day is 82
beat 83 i don't give the other guy the
228. if yours is 82 beat 82 go to 83 if
the most money you ever made in a month
is 10 000
who cares if elon musk is worth 280 you
go make 11 000
if the most sales you made in a month is
seven the other guy the number one guy
in the office at 42 you make eight beat
your prior best it's the most basic
fundamental concept of competition is
you're competing with your prior best
number two those who compete because
they want respect in an office meaning
they come in it's like look let me tell
you oh my god johnny is here johnny is
here johnny is here john that guy is a
competitor i respect him as a competitor
there's a certain level of respect you
get as a competitor right so second
level of competition is you want your
peers in the marketplace to respect you
that that respect that they're giving
you that you're a legit competitor the
highest level of competition is not for
everybody this is the part that most
people fear the highest level of
competition is when people fear you okay
now when i say fear you
there are many scenes in sports
that when a guy steps on the floor you
see the other side the players they just
kind of turn their heads like this
there's a scene
when lebron james is playing i believe
against the san antonio spurs and he
sees this young kid who was a kid at the
time kwai leonard stepped back in the
floor you should see this scene if
you've ever seen it lebron's like oh my
gosh this guy's back and why because
because kawaii knew how to guard him
there are scenes with brady when they're
ahead
against the falcons and they're
celebrating the falcons on the other
side and one of the teammates on the
falcon says dude don't celebrate there's
a guy on the other side named brady
relax fear that fear you impose michael
had it kobe had it some politicians have
it when they get on the debate stage
that's a different level of respect that
is not for everybody now if you're
listening to this and you're saying man
i want that kind of respect i want to be
feared as a dominator no problem but
just so you know like if you thought
this is demanding to beat your prior
best like if this is demanding to you
know be respected as a competitor i
can't even go like this because it's
like a skyscraper with 100 floors where
i got to take my hand for you to be
feared as a dominator it's a it's one
percent of one percent of one percent it
ain't everybody so it's very very
demanding to get to that level but all
i'm saying to you is the lowest level is
beat your prior best by the way another
thing that people get wrong with
competition is the following thing three
levels of ways people compete
most people only compete down by making
better money than my sister i'm making
better money than my brother i'm making
better money than my dad i'm making
better money than this it's always
competing down and comparing themselves
to people below them that's the weakest
level of competing it is so weak it's
cowardly you're better than that if
you're doing that change it at least
move up to the next level of competition
you shouldn't be celebrating beating
people below you second level of
competitions competing with people at
the same level as you that's fair same
level it's good you're playing with
someone that same level skill set as you
ymca ymca all that's the same level
right but the highest level of
competition that puts so much pressure
on you to improve is when you're playing
with people that are better than you now
i'm not saying my eight-year-old kid
goes and plays with michael but i am
saying my eight-year-old kid plays with
11 year olds i am saying my
eight-year-old kid goes and plays soccer
with 12 year olds that are way better
than him skill set wise he's going to
sit there and say but if this
eight-year-old kid plays with a 22 year
old it's not even a game it's unfair
because the kid's running much faster
than him but you have to be choosing at
every level test yourself to compete
against somebody that's a little bit
ahead of you maybe you can have a vision
of saying one day i want to be johnny
he's so ahead of you that's a vision but
immediate go up against people out of
you so let's recap again okay let's
recap again three things
the lowest level of competition that
everybody watching is even a person that
fears the word competition the c word
scares you more than the f word it
offends you more than the f word lowest
level just focus on beating your prior
best number two get respect from your
competitors number three only for a few
most of you are not going to commit to
this and i totally respect you for not
doing it because it's very hard it's
being feared as a dominator then
competition don't compete below compete
at the same level but if you really want
to kind of put yourself against seeing
what you're made up of start competing
with people above you if you got value
out of this video give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel
[Music]